all right we survived that mess all
Despicable Me 2 has to do is be mildly
enjoyable for children and it will win
the weekend it ain't that hard it's job
it's kind of done forward at that point
Despicable Me 2 Despicable Me 2 is about
the former villain GRU voiced by Steve
Carell he's turned adoptive father to
these three little kids and now he gets
hired by this agency to help him out and
look for another villain all the while
he's still trying to be a parent to
these kids and all the while he still
has his minions I mean isn't the first
move he didn't really impress me much
because all I saw were a bunch of little
guys punching each other I was like
punching someone who's like the most
basic of slapstick things that you can
do there wasn't much there for me I felt
the minions in this movie were a lot
funnier than they were in the first
movie it was still slapstick but they
did [ __ ] like they they got their fire
hats on and one has his hatchet he just
like digs through the wall and I was
like that he's just out of control right
now I was laughing my ass off and the
song in the end credits of this movie
just because it's the menus made at work
man they rocked it they're not my
favorite thing in the history of mankind
I'm not gonna go out and buy like a
minion squeaky toy plushie or anything
like that over this movie they cracked
me up the first half of this movie
really plays up the family aspect which
is still an aspect to the movie that I
don't connect with him like okay yeah
he's got this family and Kenny just I
don't know be a villain again but that's
not what the movies about he's not a
villain anymore
I actually got a respect the movie for
that the little kids really cute too
this is like the cutest little animated
kids since boo from monster's name
however GRU gets kind of he gets this
partner in this movie voiced by Kristen
Wiig who's a little bit of a love
interest there and I would call her an
over actor but she's not really she's
not real she's animated but if she was
real I'd be like you are an over actor
lipstick taser I'd be like wait a minute
people don't actually talk like that but
this movie is made for kids and so it's
it's okay play what I really like this
is my favorite part of the entire movie
by far el macho best part of the movie
even his introduction was awesome I mean
it's just really fast paced one frame
animation the way he takes his drink and
he slams the money down walks out the
wall it was just it's very fast you know
I like that kind of fast animation so
immediately el macho I was like you're
awesome you don't see much of him in
this movie which is a bummer but that's
what I will remember about Despicable Me
2 is el macho the second half of the
movie was really cool because you had
more spy stuff you know he's really
taken on the villain it's all going
down it's entertaining it's cool it's
all in 3d which is completely useless
and I'm burned out on 3d however I feel
like maybe I was just a really wimpy kid
that is actually factual that's not an
if that's I was a wimpy kid these things
at the end like these verbal monsters
that look like Morlocks from the old
original time machine and they just eat
everything like the Langille ears or
something I was like that's gonna
frighten children die if I were a kid
and watching this I'd be like I'll plug
in the nightlight leave the whole light
on I'm not sleeping that would have
scared the piss out of me in the end I
personally think Despicable Me 2 is
better than Despicable Me 1 if you're
already attached to the first one you'll
probably argue that point that's fine
but as someone who wasn't attached to
the first one I saw this movie I was
like oh that's that's a much better
stuff it's still strong on that parental
element so it's good for kids good for
parents good for babysitter's I will say
Despicable Me 2 is a good time no
alcohol required if you're looking for
something to do for the 4th of July and
you have a family Despicable Me 2 is
perfect for you guys right so Despicable
Me 2 have you seen it what do you think
of it do you prefer the first one or the
second one whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more